realism is not exactly what we're going
for you hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to turbo dismount
the game where I will destroy myself for
your and its Ament
oh alright
hi guys and welcome to turbo dismount I
don't know why I didn't find out about
this game until just yesterday but man
is it exactly what I want in a game
anyway so you're in a car by just
somebody to explain I love it already
because I was able to put my face and a
giant mustache on the car that is
absolutely astonishing to me and you
should go and kill yourself can't kill
yourself very well doing something slow
is that but I put these turbo pads here
and just oh here I am okay I'm over here
so anyway I haven't played it much but I
got a feel for the system it's got a
replay mechanic that you can just play
and then reverse image but anyway I got
a lot of stuff to show you so show you I
got a lot of stuff to dick around with
that's what I got to do alright so this
pose ain't working for me you can
actually change the pose up and you can
be sitting up here and my favorite of
course is this one because for some
reason my character model which is the
female character model by the way sticks
this butt out you're shaking it around
that's awesome
and a booty shaking we gotta go let's go
oh my god oh they didn't stop for
anything today where did I go okay there
oh there I am okay oh wow this is my
favorite feature of it it's so group of
puppets oh shoot Oh
stair dismount I didn't make it though I
need to make it farther nananana I don't
think that's gonna help you keep wanting
to shake your butt but I really don't
think it helps okay let's write all
right already scraping your feet on the
ground I like it I like it I like it
cue the dramatic music nothing is ever
gonna live up to that that's just too
perfect there's no way that I could
possibly beat it oh can even you look so
sad though as if you're regretting all
your even see your dad like this is a
bad idea
too bad yeah
that's almost max power right there come
on oh my god hey things are looking
pretty good I feel good about this oh no
realism is not exactly what we're going
for you
coming let's see that again in slow
motion again to me again I'm so relaxed
I'm just like a little bit care in the
world everything's gonna be just fine
I think it's really gonna help us is
coming at this at an angle and a
different pose of course oh oh
paint me like one of your I think that
was absolutely max power right there - I
wasn't going now we just need an
exercise in speed so let's see what
happens
soup oh my car disappeared oh I'm sorry
I wonder what mystery vehicle I'm coming
down the runway on now Oh Oh what the
hell oh hi can't be bothered by anything
life is such a drag I wonder where I'm
going
and it's still going all right bring on
the Corley not a Harley it Oh
that's encased you down to death you
[ __ ] stop sweating your legs like that
even though your leg is clearly all the
way over there nothing could go wrong -
all right so that was turbo dismount
that is amazingly fun I am putting this
on my list of games to play with Bob
when he comes to visit me or I go to
visit him because us playing this game
together with beats so much fun anyway
if you want to see more of it let me
know in the comments below thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video